what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
delving into the newest revelations in
the black clovers story including the
epic battle against Vanek ax and Meggie
Kula the reveal of Anika's second magic
attribute and Noelle's brand new
transformation that has allowed her to
strike a blow against her mother's
alleged murderer there is so much to
talk about so let's get into it if you
enjoy the black clover content on this
channel and you want us to keep it go
and please leave a like to let me know
and to help with the YouTube algorithm
and if you happen to be new to anime
lore or you just haven't subscribed yet
please consider subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications if you don't click the
bell and then select the option that
says all you're still gonna miss a lot
of our videos even if you're subscribed
it's just how you do works a big
shout-out to my editor and fellow black
clover superfan Dakota broski please
show him some love for all the work he
does for us here on this channel
and check out his channel link in the
description finally this video will of
course contain black clover manga
spoilers we're talking about the very
latest events in the manga so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned the latest chapter begins right
in the thick of the battle that started
at the very end of the previous chapter
Laura Pacheco Noel and mimosa were
taking on Vanek ax and one of her simps
and Noel wastes no time in using one of
her most Opie spells sea dragons roar at
this point vantika reveals her other
magic attribute the extra one that she
possesses aside from curse magic it
turns out that her second magic type is
blood magic and Wanaka uses blood magic
to create some sort of giant grotesque
monster which is able to stop Doyle's
water dragon in its tracks that thing
that vantika created looks a lot like
something right out of stranger things
and it definitely creeped me out
Vanek a is not impressed by Noel spell
and she even mocks Noel Vanek a-- asks
if that water snake thing she manifested
was actually supposed to be a real
attack meanwhile mimosa is duking it out
with the tongue magic
pervert who had been revived by Manica
in the previous chapter it turns out
that mimosa managed to cover her
opponent with magic controlling weed
seeds and this causes the simps body to
become covered in weeds he is then also
apparently hit with Vanegas own blood
magic at least that's what it looks like
I'm not sure whether she hits him on
purpose or whether he just got in the
way but regardless the tongue magic
pervert is fine and he praises lady
Monica and both of her magic attributes
this guy is truly a committed simp
simple even in the middle of a dangerous
battle and even as he himself is getting
hit I mean I guess you got to respect
that in its own way realizing that
vantika can use two types of magic
Noel thinks back to when Laura Pacheco
had explained to them that all three
members of the dark triad can use two
types of magic they have their own magic
attribute the one that they were born
with and they have the magic attribute
of the demon who was possessing them
this is something that most of us had
already assumed was the case but it is
now fully confirmed by Beaver girl
as far as Zenon goes if I recall
correctly we've only ever seen him use
his bone magic but in his battle against
Yami we did see that Dante could use
both gravity magic and he was also able
to use some strange form of healing
magic that allows him to manipulate his
flesh and heal even the deepest wounds
since Laura Pacheco had already fought
vantika once before she does have some
idea about how vantika fights and how to
potentially defeat her so beaver girl no
Elle and mimosa have all been training
with this in mind but the big question
is this did a little chica witness the
true extent of Anika's power back when
they fought for the first time or does
vantika still have some tricks up her
sleeve tricks that can be used to
surprise her opponents and throw them
off their game as bieber girl activates
the water spirit Undine and as water
rushes all around vantika banika wonders
if Zenon and Dante are having fun
according to vantika
she has the best job of all because she
is allowed to go out and kill Laura
Pacheco meanwhile Zenon and Dante can go
all out because they need to bring back
the users of world tree magic and
art magic when she hears this Noelle
isn't sure why the dark triad would be
going after the users of dark magic and
world tree magic but Laura chica
remember something because the Queen's
of the Hart Kingdom inherit the
knowledge and experience of all the
previous Queens beaver girl realizes
what the dark triad is up to she knows
about the tree of cliff auth and the
Triads plan to open the portal between
this world and the demon world judging
by the panel that we see as la tapa
chica makes this connection we can
expect a lot of death and destruction if
this plan succeeds Bieber girl then
warns her comrades that if they allow
the dark triad to complete their mission
over 90% of this continents population
will be killed off and the world as we
know it will end Noel is shocked to hear
this but Monica thinks that this is a
great and exciting prospect
if over 90% of the population is
destroyed then only the strongest will
remain and vanakkam wants to live in a
world where only the strongest survive
she doesn't have any interest in
coexisting with weaklings and at this
point Veronica reminds me of a yawn that
have female Gilgamesh although to be
fair Gilgamesh is a bit of a yandere
anyway realizing how insane vantika is
Bieber girl knows that they cannot let
the Triad win they must stop vantika
right here and now because the fate of
the entire world rests on their victory
Laura Pacheco then combines mana zone
with the rune magic of the heart Kingdom
in order to trap vantika inside this
massive cloud made of water and
according to a little patch Iike this
water will cut the strength of vana cos
blood magic in half and at the same time
this water will make Noelle's magic
stronger
Noel then proceeds to use a brand new
transformation Valkyrie armor mermaid
form and she proceeds to pierce Vanegas
torso with her water spear and the
attack does look like it was effective
at least on the surface however although
vantika looks hurt physically she merely
smiles and says good one and that is
where this chap
her ends with Laura Pacheco Noel a
mimosa doing their best and surpassing
their limits
but unfortunately for them Vanek appears
to be far too strong to be taken down so
easily and this is just the beginning it
is clear that at this point veronica has
not been defeated and the only question
now is whether this battle will continue
until our heroes do find some way of
defeating her or whether Anika is
actually going to win this fight and
force the heroes to deal with the
aftermath as was the case in the fight
between xenon and the Golden Dawn
personally I'm thinking that vanakkam
might actually end up killing a little
pet chica at some point either during
this fight or later on and then the
water spirit on Dean will be inherited
by Noel which will greatly increase
Noelle's overall strength but I'm just
speculating obviously I kind of don't
want this to happen because Beiber girl
has really grown on me with her
quirkiness what do you guys think is
vantika going to kill Laura Pacheco
forcing Noel to take control of on Dean
or is something else going to happen is
there a way for the three girls to
actually defeat vanakkam and speaking of
Anika I find it interesting that she
possesses blood magic just like the
witch Queen and she also possesses curse
magic we know that the witch Queen was
also very skilled when it came to curses
and to removing them
so is vantika somehow connected to the
witch queen is she a former witch or is
she somehow related to the witch Queen
herself
we know that the queen of the witches
has been alive for a very long time and
that she knows a lot about the demons so
I wouldn't be surprised if there is some
sort of connection between the two with
that said how strong do you think Vanek
ax is at her very strongest and how
strong do you think that Noel is after
the time-skip do you like her new
transformation the Valkyrie armor
mermaid form and do you think that she
stands a chance against vantika or is
she doomed to lose this battle just like
hasta los - dante and despite his recent
power-up please don't know what you guys
think down in the comments below I
honestly can't wait to see what happens
next I'm glad that we learned what
vantika second magic attribute was and
i'm glad that we are finally seeing
post-time skipped Noel in
[ __ ] but we still need a lot more
information in order to determine where
this fight will actually go from here
whatever happens though I'm excited to
keep reading this awesome series and I
hope that you are too if you enjoyed
this video you want to see more please
leave a like to let me know and if you
happen to be new to anime uproar or
maybe you just haven't subscribed please
consider subscribing and hitting that
bell to turn on all notifications feel
free to hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram ads anime uproar I want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
opera patrons who make videos like this
one possible a very special thank you to
a friend a a disciple of Lord Twigg o
himself and I can't forget our the one
tear patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including Ingrid ah a lull
an atom of the world steelers tyson qui
dino acquired respect pat a heffa
Jonathan king deci be Brandon Aviles
Papa Smurf Emperor otaku and Richie
Martinez finally thank you also to all
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
Jason Wilson King zelgius Anatole
Cassatt ski on hell Cruz hi Sparky
sixty-five cricket XP Ted no Ted Joe
Stanton very Gucci alicia akhter animal
a 69 jessica calif on dino commune water
bonnie parks so dr 12 rothwyn day ora
emperor mitch loves anime cynical Kraken
and JCCC waka if you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you please consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]